salut, aujourd'hui je suis avec Astrid
Astrid on s'est rencontrés à Nantes avec mon spectacle
c'était au théatre sans nom, je crois
exactement
et c'était les premières dates de tournée du spectacle, a l'époque
on est vendredi et le vendredi c'est quoi ? c'est le jours de l'euromillion
j'ai envie qu'on joue avec ça. Daccord ?
j'vais te demander, Astrid, par rapport a l’euro million
d'imaginer un ...
d'imaginer ce que tu achèterais soit en voyage, soit comme objet si tu gagnais a l’euro million
ok? En général c'est facile mais tu peut me piéger
j'sai pas en prenant un râteau, un yo-yo, ou n'importe quoi, ou en décidant d'aller en vacances à Dunkerque. c'est ton choix
j'vais poser la caméra là, comme ça on pourra bien se voir tout les deux
on est vraiment dans la rue les copains
j'ai juste besoin de ...
oh oui !
c'est clair que c'est de la street de chez street
j'essaie de faire rapide par ce que je ne coupe plus ces passages là
par ce qu'on m'a accusé de trop couper dans le cœur même du tour
et que en fait il y avait des feintes
en fait je sais qu'il faudrait pas que je tienne compte de ça à chaque fois mais j'en tiens compte
c'est plus fort que moi
j'ai besoin juste de recentrer un tout petit peu, de verrouiller
Est ce que ..... Heu... Est ce que c'est un voyage
-Oui !
C'est un voyage d'accord ok
Donc il va falloir que je trouve le pays en fait
C'est ça ok je vais chercher
ce pays là, Astrid
heuuu.... je vais pas te poser
de questions si t'y es allée, pas allée .....
parce qu'on pourrait penser que j'ai discuté avec toi
donc je vais juste te demander déjà de ressentir toi
donc je vais juste te demander toi de ressentir
Comment tu te sentirais la bas
Est-ce que tu te sentirais bien ...
Juste de ressentir, hein ? pas de me dire.
Si tu te sentirais bien au chaud ... ou au froid ... ou un peu stressée parce que c'était une blague que tu m'avais mise où ce genre de choses.
- euh, ouais
T'arrives à te projeter ?
- euh c'est, c'est bon
C'est bon ? Ok . Ha, on est plutôt détente ! Ca va, on est plutôt détendu, ok.
euh ...
Je vais dire des choses. Je vais faire des affirmations, tu me réponds jamais.
Tu peux me répondre que mentalement
Si t'as envie de formuler une réponse, tu la fais dans ta tête.
Voilà. Comment faire taire Astrid
- Ho ! [rires]
Attends, je met comme ça, qu'on te voit bien.
Donc tu réponds que dans ta tête.
Ça peut être dans un pays chaud, c'est peut-être ... peut-être qu'on parle français. Peut-être qu'on ne parle pas français.
- Hum
Peut-être, euh ... t'as vu c'est dur, hein, de pas répondre !
- C'est dur ouais
- Je dois faire des mimiques, je sais pas
C'est peut-être plus à l'ouest de la France
C'est à dire en traversant l'Atlantique
ou c'est plutôt de l'autre coté
Ha ! elle me dit rien ... ok
- Hum, je ...
Oui, parce que là j'ai l'impression que tu le sais pas toi même en fait
- Si, si ! [rires] Si, si, c'est bon.
Ok. J'ai une piste d'idée
Je vais peut-être quand même essayer de faire un lettre par lettre
Alors attends, j'ai toujours le bloc-notes quelque part
Oui. Et un crayon. Est-ce j'ai un crayon ?
J'ai un crayon ici, super.
ok
Je vais noter mes premières impressions.
- Daccord
Pas le pays en lui même
Je vous fait voir que à vous
Est-ce que tu peux me dire si il fait chaud ou froid ?
- Chaud
Est ce que tu peux me dire si on parle français ?
- Non
Bon, pour l'instant j'étais à "chaleur" et "pas français"
- Parfait !
C'est ça que je vous avez fait voir : "chaleur" et "pas français".
C'est mal écrit mais c'est ce que j'avais
- Terrible !
Ok, pour moi c'est à l'Est de la France. On survole pas la mer et on va de l'autre coté.
Je pense avoir bon.
Pour moi on part du coté de l'Asie quoi.
- Hum, hum
[rire]
- Je dois te répondre ou pas là ? Je sais pas
Elle ne sait plus. Moi non plus, je sais même plus ce que je te demande !
- [rire] Si, vas-y, t'étais sur l'Asie
Je vais essayer de trouver la première lettre. Tu penses juste à la première lettre
Je prends ton poignet au vol.
Ca peut être
A. B. C. D. E. F. G. H. I. J. K. L. M. N. O. P. Q. R. S. T.
Un petit T !
Ou juste avant ou juste aprés, hein,je sais pas encore tout à fait.
Ok, je l'ai écrit ici !
Est-ce que tu peut me dire exactement dans quel pays tu partirais si tu gagnais ce soir a l'euromillion ?
- En Thailande
En Thaïlande ?
En THAILAAAAAAAAAAANDE
- [rire] T'es un ouf !
C'est pas un billet pour la Thaïlande mais je te souhaite de gagner ce soir à l'euromillion
- Ok
SI jamais tu as joué !
- Non
Et oui, c'est ça
Parce que moi aussi je rêve de gagner à l'euromillion mais en fait je ne joue pas donc je risque pas de gagner tout de suite
- Enorme, merci
Y'as pas plus street que ce qu'on vient de faire Astrid
- Ouais, la c'est ... ouais, très bien.
En réalité je dois partir au théâtre, on avait pas le temps de faire la vidéo et puis on s'est dit: On l'as fait ? on l'as fait pas?
Et on se retrouve dans la rue en train de la faire en fait
- Voila, tout à fait.
Si vous avez aimé la vidéo n’hésitez pas à me le faire savoir en nous laissant un petit
- Pouce en l'air
- Pouce en l'air [rires]
Elle a as osé faire le
POUCE EN L'AIR !
On est vendredi, le vendredi c'est donc toujours un tour de mentalisme que je fais à quelqu'un. Je vous fais participer à ça.
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la chaîne, vous pouvez aussi laisser un petit commentaire.
Et le Mental vlog c'est 1 vidéo par jour pendant 1 an alors rendez-vous demain à 11h pour le prochain Mental vlog.
CIAO !